it's expensive and impractical and it
doesn't always guarantee results but
tracking terrorist suspects is one of
the most important roles for mi5 and our
police so how do they do it
mi5 have around 3,000 subjects of
interest or SOS but they can't keep an
eye on all of them all of the time
24-hour surveillance takes at least two
teams of 15 specialists each working a
12-hour shift long-term observation may
take up to four teams which could mean
around 60 people add in undercover cars
vans and motorbikes as well as all the
surveillance gear and this becomes an
expensive job and remember this is all
for one person 60 people for all 3,000
suspects adds up to 180 thousand
officers and spooks and that's far more
staff than all of the UK police and mi5
have combined so they have to pick their
targets carefully when mi5 received new
intelligence that kicks off a formal
process they check the suspect for links
to any existing investigations check
across the mi5 database to see if they
have any information on them and then
try to assess just how much of a threat
they pose the investigations are sorted
into four priority categories
re-engagement risk uncorroborated
intelligence extremist activity and the
highest priority attack planning the SOS
are also put into tiers tier one main
targets tier two key contacts of the
main targets and tier three contacts of
the tier one and two targets once they
decide which investigations are the most
urgent the surveillance begins how
effective is this process well we really
don't know the government say they
stopped at least 22 attacks in the past
few years but some of the highest
profile terror attacks in the UK in
recent years were carried out by SOS the
suspect had been recently released from
prison where he had been serving a
sentence for Islamist related terrorism
offences Westminster Bridge attacker
Khalid Masood and Manchester Arena
bomber Salman Abady were both considered
closed subjects of interest Stratham
attacker Sudesh a man had also recently
been released from prison as had the
2019 London Bridge attacker Osman Khan
whether these people should have been
considered a higher priority is up for
debate but it goes to show just how
difficult it really is to track terror
suspects and how high the price can be
if they slip through the hands of the
authorities